Beta glue cans are in the red zone. So you looked up what foods have beta glue can in them besides mushrooms, which are also were in the red zone, and it includes foods from my green zone beans eggplant. So this is testing the whole food.
So when they test beans eggplant sweet potato and they're in the green zone, then it's okay to eat beans eggplant and sweet potato.
So you weren't having trouble with anything in that those with those foods. So it's okay to eat those.
All grocery store animal protein was in the red zone for me. That means this person has to not eat that for a period of time.
What about glandular supplements that have thyroid thymus and lung tissue or freeze dried liver tissue in them?
Really good question. That's just that gray factor. I personally would just avoid those for a period of time.
Again, you're going to do everything you can to try to heal the gut. You don't want anything that's going to cause inflammation.
I would rather air caution and do everything I possibly can to calm the gut down. Now you personally have got symptoms, which is kind of a blessing because as you start working through this, you can kind of guide your care, like adding different foods back that are in the yellow zone.
One at a time like we discussed, adding those back and watching for symptoms. If you notice any bloating, you notice any tummy upset that you can take that back out again.
So I would air a caution as far as, oh, do I really need a thymus and lung tissue right now? Can I go without that for a few weeks to months? Yes, you can.
You know, I fried potatoes would be in the green zone and baked potatoes would be in the yellow zone seems weird. No, not weird at all because as you cook things different way, it alters the protein.
It's the protein that is contained the amino acids that you that's how you you create antibodies against that. So fried potatoes have a different protein, amino acid content, then baked potatoes, then raw potatoes.
It's it's the formulation of the amino acid content. So when you cook a food, it could be different than when food is raw. I think on yours cooked asparagus was in the yellow zone or green or red zone and raw asparagus was okay in the green zone.
Why is that? Because when you cook something, it changes it and they test for fried potatoes. A lot of people will eat fried potatoes, right? French fries and deep fried potato things doesn't seem real good for you, but it the protein changes when you fry it or cook it or bake it. It's a different protein than when it's raw.
So they test for those things. Of course, this test can't test for everything. So I want to try a food that's not on the list at all. Do I just save that? Try that later on? I would. I would try that later on so that you can measure it because you know, if you're like, I just not getting better. Let's say you go off all the stuff on the red and yellow listed. You're doing really good and added.
You know, bull broth and soup and got healing things that we discussed to your diet and you're just not getting better. Then there are some other things that's causing some issues too that we need to dig into.
So it is a trial and error. You got to try to heal your gut and you could be extremely pleased when you get to the point where you feel like you're really making progress and healing your gut and other things are going to get better.
There were a problem too, like maybe cancer. So this is where treating yourself holistically. Everybody on this call and people that will listen to it afterwards are like in the holistic care. Well, this is like the ultimate holistic care.
You're not just treating a disease cancer or an autoimmune disease. How do I fix this? Well, how you fix this is fix your whole body. You've got to look at these other things because everything is connected.
Everything's tied together. So this is you've got to count. This is a blessing. You've got to look at it differently so that you know you're this is how you're going to get better.